[Musique]
des rues désertes et de nombreux
commerces aux rideaux baissés
ce matin le centre ville de dijon
semblait vidée de ses habitants
alors que la plupart des supermarchés
sont censées restées fermées cette
grande enseigne est ouverte le 25
décembre
une aubaine pour ces retardataires on a
fait au moins six magasins et c'est le
seul comme une dame m'a dit qu'ils
étaient ouverts
on essaye dépêchés de venir pourquoi
acheter quoi les des petits manques les
petits manques apéritif les bouteilles
qui sont vides bien qu'on entraîne des
plaines ainsi à et puis voilà tout de
dernière minute je vais je peux acheter
quelque chose peut-être dia truite fumée
ou du saumon
voilà quoi pour terminer en beauté cette
boulangerie aussi a tout prévu
plus d'une centaine de commandes ont été
préparés et un flux continu de clients à
défiler toute la matinée dans la
boutique
nous avons ouvert exclusivement surtout
pour dépanner les gens parce que bah on
sait que c'est toujours une grande
journée et que toujours à la dernière
minute il ya des gens qui arrivent d'un
petit peu à l'improviste gens des sceaux
est en quête d'un ancien type tout ça
hier soir les employés n'ont pas tous
profiter pleinement du réveillon
car ce matin il fallait assurer le
réveil a sonné tôt
clairement il a sonné vers 6h30 à peu
près ça fait toujours plaisir de venir
servir des gens qui sont l'âme dans la
bonne humeur
moi ça me fait plaisir en tout cas alors
ce matin j'ai préparé toutes les
commente j'ai vu venue accompagner un
peu les vingt deux également parce que
on en a beaucoup donc pour avancer un
peu en ce jour de noël il y avait quand
même bien des commerçants aux petits
soins pour leurs clients fêtes de fin
d'année aux nazis